hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village before we get started i just
want to say
if i look tired it's because i still
have makeup on from filming the edge of
sleep
also there's a new episode of
distractible available right now through
the link in the description below
the link right down there the link that
you should click on right now
wherever you listen to podcasts you can
click that link it will take you to
every single podcast location that the
podcast is available at
and if you don't know what distractable
is then
we have a bit of a problem i thought we
went through this do i need to have
another lecture with you to tell you
about distractible and to talk to you
about all the incredible features that
are available over at distractible
and how much you'll laugh you'll cry and
you'll cry
from listening to distractible so click
the link down below
or after this episode when you're done
with watching this you can click the
link in the description below and you
can go listen to distractible or you can
do it now
that's also an option okay so i've made
a decision
i don't know how much i consulted your
opinion about this but i made it just no
i made a decision and the decision is as
follows no
not this way hold on i'm gonna tell you
the decision as soon as i get back to
the place i need to be
okay so the decision that i have made is
as follows
this guy spent all this time to set up
this wonderful trap for me
which is definitely a trap but i don't
care because i'm expecting a trap
he set all of this up for me and there's
a tunnel right here
now i could go around i could but also
i'm thinking that he knows that i would
go around i'm thinking he thinks that
i'm kind of smart he respects me a
little bit which i gotta admire about
him back
so i'm gonna go straight up the front
here i'm gonna right go right down into
the throat of this
that's the only way for me it's the only
way i know
because i'm a badass
[Music]
hey babe look look babe
is that your castle or is that not your
castle who
where why what when
see they set up all this lovely art
yeah lovely art it's beautiful
beautiful
[Applause]
who wants some flower you want to get
flowered
you're gonna get flowed you anyone get
flowed
my dude oh hey what's up you want to get
flowed
you get a face full of flower hey come
on
come over here get flowed what's up my
dude
what's up what's up you want to get oh
stoop
come on get flowed come on come over
here try me oh yeah
oh you're gonna pull out a weapon isn't
that just on fire
idiot fool loser nerd
you're so stupid oh yeah yeah
what's up what's up what's up
no i forgot that these guys take a lot
guarding doesn't seem to be as working
as well as i thought it would be let's
try a good old gun
let's try putting face and gun bang
there's a dude
you done oh you just fell over man
i really don't have too many of these
bullets hello
well there you are oh okay all right
point don't make it easy for me there
you go
crystal skull only i could actually sell
it for ammo
you know this doesn't seem as like
traptastic this seems just straight up
normal oh
where'd your head go whoa
who the hell do you think you are
who the hell okay you know what this is
kind of lame
is it too late to go back the other way
maybe i could
get the best of both worlds and maybe i
could just do this i thought it was
going to be like a fun house of mirrors
this is just straight up just combat
that's dumb this is dumb i'm going the
other way
you guys suck i actually didn't listen
to any of your recommendations because i
i didn't look at the comments because i
feared that someone would spoil it
so i didn't look at all i tricked you it
was a clever ruse
that also is a trick the only true path
is this way
i know this i feel this
i feel it so strongly hey what's up
heisenborgio
what's up my dude hey wait let me craft
some ammo that i'm definitely going to
be able to use
doink
[Laughter]
now this is way more fun this is most
certainly hey what's up boink sorry
oh oh hey what's up pal
how about wanna please
[Music]
nice nice loser what's up
pal do i have any yeah i do
hey why don't you come over here let's
come over here buddy
hey buddy hey buddy
why don't you jump up here again oh he
did it
i can't believe he actually did it why
don't you go wait wait wait wait wait
okay all right let's
watch you leap across the chasm over
here why don't you do that why don't you
do that
oh [ __ ] was that like a weak point hey
come on leap
leap leave my leafy person
come on leap leap do it you won't
you won't why oh
hello leap oh these [ __ ]
no that's not leaping
stop it hey buddy did not see you there
holy crap do i have any goop okay
did not know that it was uh it was pound
town that quick
okay let me sploosh a little can you not
yeah wait wait buddy uh this is going
wrong-footedly
all right you gotta hit this mine come
here hit the mine
okay he's not hitting the mine guys i
don't know how to break it to you but
he's really not hitting
the mine
can you hit that mine
can you mine
come here buddy he just does not wanna
okay he's really
okay he's being okay maybe i gotta get
some stopping power in this
bang oh
miss there we go you like that
okay he's kind of tough
is there any way to kill him is there
like no way to kill him
he's getting quick and i got one more of
these
let me kaboom you up
oh what's going on here what's all this
wait am i supposed to be
all right well that was cool i got the
meats
today's the day the jolly merchant stops
by he always gives me old newspapers i
know miranda forbids them but news of
the outside world is so fascinating
there was one thing that piqued my
interest in the last one it was an
article about some medicine company
i don't remember the name but their
emblem looked familiar
it was the same symbol on the giant's
chalice i'm pretty sure i saw the same
one painted on the walls in the cave too
that radiating umbrella image really
stands out
what's some outsider company emblem
doing here i wonder if it had anything
to do with that man that stayed here all
those years ago
nah i'm overthinking it yeah i'm sure
you are buddy
i'm sure you are am i supposed to go
back and kill this guy what's the what's
the deal hey are you here
all right
let me finish him off i guess don't call
more
birds oh my god more birds
okay there's no way this guy is like
invincible or something there's no way
okay hit it this time goodness gracious
just hit the damn thing
there we go oh [ __ ]
are you still alive
oh my god
what is this what is this nonsense
does this guy not die or something is
this just one of those no die dudes
bang oh my god
oh my god
how are you you're wasting my shooty
guns
flop please
whoa hey bud what's
here we up oh there he goes can i get
your axe
can i have that whoa he gave it to me
thanks pal um if that was just worth
money then um
i don't know if that was totally worth
it but
it's a lot of effort for not a lot of
reward
well i feel like i mean
kind of cool i guess it's too big to use
well you don't know how big i
am lady demi what do you think what do
you think lady dimma doom
what do you think what are you thunkling
all right fine
man i really wish i had my grenade
launcher
kind of sucks that i don't have that
anymore okay well that was much more fun
than the other way
that was way more fun woohoo
i guess i don't know is that cool wait
who's father
who's father nicholas saint nick
santa claus
one of the four founders okay probably
not
okay got some coin
okay open this up
uh this was just
a side path what's up bud
mam what's up bud bam what's up bud
bam what's up bud oh what's up bud
what's up bud what's up bud yeah yeah
you fall over
oh no you're not dead you think you're
getting yeah you fall
you fall over thanks you must have
followed me i guess
what a waste for you
right well i guess it wasn't really a
choice anyway i just had to go one way
or another
all right cool i'll deal with it fine oh
me
um hey is anybody left alive there sure
were a lot of you
kind of really thin in the oh my god i
didn't actually want there to be more
hey hey stop
yeesh
did i get him i think i got him
okay hey stop
did i shoot that out of the air please
tell me i shot that out here
holy crap okay no
don't don't
do not don't do that
coming for you coming for you baby i'm
coming for you
i'm coming for you is very cute you know
it's very cute
it's very cute it's very cute but
uh ultimately no i'm gonna go with a no
this is all very cute okay it's very
cute
it's super cute
very very cute boom
oh oh yeah yeah okay yeah uh-huh i wish
i had something besides a shotgun to do
this but here we go
ow all right
well that was effective there we go that
would have been helpful a little bit ago
oh well late late never late lever
late blever better blatant blubber
i'm getting a lot of goodies
one i'm guessing there's another one on
the other side that i gotta do am i
still recording oh
you better believe i am
all right um oh hey what's up more
people great this is
man you guys are persistent i really
wish i saved those exploded barrels now
really wish i saved it uh there's got to
be another explody barrel around here
that i can draw him too
if i'd have known that it was going to
be an explodey barrel necessary
situation
i would have you know saved the explodey
barrels
maybe oh well now there's no one he got
you
get out of the way get run die fall
apart bam
bam try me [ __ ] bam
try me [ __ ] bam try me [ __ ] bam
there we go whoop hey no
you gotta be almost dead you have to be
come on
oh how are you still alive
oh my god i hit you with a shotgun did i
not
like the ultra werewolf okay thank you
for that that was very helpful very
helpful
oh that oh my god they just never end
okay i just gotta go
this is a great time to remind you about
the link in the description for
distractible
our excellent podcast with bobbinwood oh
do i gotta go and
pull the other lever quickly i'm
probably gonna do that
probably one of those things i'll do it
i'll do it
oh no it's done what what am i is there
another secret lover somewhere
hi oh my god
stop no stop
okay i guess i won't push him away i'll
just grunt
can i please can i please
oh my god why
okay it's open i guess here i go
stronghold okay you got it buddy
i did it hey eisenberg i beat your
puzzle both sides of it i'm just that
good
okay no one's here to greet me that's a
little rude thank you i guess all right
whatever
whatever i missed castle dimitrisk
i missed castle tiffany rescue so much
oh the fond memories i have from those
times
i just miss it you know i just miss
castle's goody baby
whoa hey i don't know if i can jump that
in fact i can't
this looks slightly familiar
i'm missing something here there's some
kind of a goodie
up there i got it nope that wasn't it
huh yeah whatever i ain't completionist
all right heisenberg whatever you got
i'm ready for it come on
[Applause]
what's up hey what's up hey how you
doing
hey good to see you why don't y'all
gather around this barrel
that'd be cool yeah come on oh you're
quick oh you're all quick oh you're
speedy
oh no hit it
that's better that's better that's
better that's better that's more like it
okay oh hey hey hey hey dick
dick dick stop stop
stop stop i have the high ground
you can't win you're the chosen one
you're supposed to bring balance
what just dropped in front of me come on
yeah yeah all of you all of you all of
you come on come on come at me
come at me all of you all of you come on
you know you wanna and three two one
give me give me ow okay none of that no
plea
no after i really
um
this is a great time to remind you guys
about distractible it's a new podcast my
way and i have this verb
this must be they're dead how how did i
get
this is supposed to be on like easy or
something how
[Applause]
who
i who know i don't know i don't know i
don't know i don't
i don't know i don't know i don't know i
don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i don't if i know
the button
[Music]
oh you think you're funny do you oh you
think you're funny
oh you think you're funny
[Music]
oh you think you're ha ha funny funny oh
you think you're ha ha funny funny jokes
oh yeah you think you're funny yeah oh
you think you're hilarious oh yeah you
think you're so
funny oh yeah oh you're so okay
who dares okay get out in the open here
closer please any day now any day now oh
my god
got him doing good doing good
oops missed you got him
[Applause]
double tap mike
fergunus
excellent they are sure giving me a lot
of stuff though
gotta appreciate that i appreciate it
appreciate it appreciate you okay you
two come up here we're gonna go up
up the stairs you guys are coming ah why
no do not we're going up he's stairsy
we're going up
he's stairsy we're going up he's stairsy
okay
we're going to go up he's stairsy where
are you where are you yeah come on come
on up here stairs
stairs he upsets stairs he up sees the
stairs he boom
yeah that's right how how how
okay ah i see i meant to grab that
gunpowder but it didn't give it to me
probably i'm just supposed to run i i
imagine that actually i might i might
just
actually be supposed to run
interesting interesting interesting okay
oh i'm not ready i did not see you there
i heard big guy and i don't know why i
didn't think
hey look out for the big guy um
okay listen listen big guy
listen big pal listen pal
big pal listen guy who's big
i sure wish i had my grenade launcher
boy that was an oversight wow
this is a terrible predicament that i'm
in
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay wait
wait wait watch this what's this what's
this i'm so smart
so goddamn equip it equip it
i thought go away
what do i have nothing
[Applause]
all right big guy you and me oh no hang
on this is me and the big guy
hold on hold on no it's just me oh my
god
oh my god
oh my god every time i block and then
then you attack
[Music]
oh my god why is my why is my mouth
sensitive he's so high
mother rubber
why do i not have my god damn explody
blue
well that's really great link in the
description distractible podcast
oh my god how many
how many
if you don't go listen to the podcast
right the hell now
i'm going to do exactly what i did these
werewolves to you
okay link's in the description we have a
freaking deal
that's the way it is and these [ __ ]
need to shut up because i have
nothing with which to shoot them
okay good could i have just gone out
this door though
please link in the description is just
tractable
distractible pocket
we work
who now am i recording yes ooh
okay yeah squeeze through pardon me
oh okay i don't know what's happening
that's weird that's very weird
that's very weird
okay
all right where am i now what am i doing
the king's orders finally arrived
withdraw it is most vexing that we must
abandon the border stronghold to these
heretics
if i had but a little more time i know i
might be able to turn the tides of this
battle
nay i should not put on airs it is my
curiosity that ties me to this place
there are a number of ruins within the
vicinity which the locals say are very
ancient
the ceremony site with four giant
statues the caves with murals
carved on the walls the stone plinth
they called the giants chalice
where did the people who built them come
from where did they go
it irks me that we must abandon this
place without knowing
yeah it irks me too buddy it irks me too
pal
really i'm irked ugh i've never been
so irked ever in my life
i feel you on that one buddy i feel you
on that one pal i
feel ya if only i had my grenade
launcher where's my
um
oh god oh no
guys no please i didn't know i thought i
didn't have it
oh no oh no i really
guys oh no this is not a bit but maybe
it is
oh my god is it better if it's a bit
oh my god i literally
i thought it was like in a storage chest
but there isn't even a storage chest in
this game
i thought
i legitimately thought i really actually
thought
that i didn't have it
i actually 100 thought i didn't have it
what's happening that's not good no
that's not good
what is it why oh hey bud
what's up pal
whoa man i wish i had that sniper rifle
or something hey what's up pal
hey how you doing belt boy i wish i
could back up a little quicker
uh-huh
okay gave me some pipe bombs i'm gonna
use them
let's see if we can do some uh some ring
around the rosies
oh well that doesn't really help me um
maybe if i run i run around yeah yeah
yeah okay
right your feet nice another one
oh that was a shitty throw thank you
got him okay cool cool cool we're good
we're good we're good
you better not be calling for help
oh here he comes
this is a bad place to be
okay okay
uh can i switch ammos where's the other
ammo can i switch ammo how do i switch
ammos
f f i'm effing i'm effing i'm
f'ing yay
hey bud uh can i wait oh [ __ ]
i do not have that many bullets left uh
that's not good
what if i go through here nope what is
that what is that what is that what is
happening
that's your girth it's his girth
everybody
ah your girth
very impressive um i have very little
left because i don't have my sniper
rifle but i do have some
magnum
oh no not no not now
oh who who me
me
[Applause]
yay
hey what's up bud
good thing i got so many of these oh
that's not
good oh that's bad oh that's bad oh
that's bad oh that's bad oh that's bad
okay well you miss so pretty pitiful if
you ask me
i don't think he did i don't think he
asked me
okay uh so what happens when i have
absolutely nothing and for some reason i
can't get these other
you know oh flashbangs ah
man i have a lot of sniper rifles um
time to bust out the
magnum i guess oh never mind
crystal hammer eat [ __ ]
nice one good job he really showed him
you really gave him the business there
ethan you really told him off you really
gave him what for
you really give him the you you did it
you
did it you did it you big [ __ ] you did
it
i should have the sniper rifle on me
shouldn't i oh
babe what do you think of this place
maybe even better than your your castle
you know if you think about it
maybe babe what do you think you're
speechless i know
i understand i get it i get it
you don't need to say anything no large
crystalline is your marker still in here
crystal crystal there's probably like a
shiny up in the top that i could shoot
and it would knock it out
oh yep oh there's multiple okay
well i can't
i literally have no bullets left
there's so many shinies that i could
shoot and i have
no
yes i'm not getting them
oh here we go come on bullets yes
there we go there we go
there we go put those legs
okay a one
oh vivianite
there's one over here
probably okay let me just look
nothing there
uh-huh
okay got him okay we're good let's get
out of here
i don't know what the vivian knight is
unless it's that thing for that necklace
that i have don't i have a necklace with
one hole
yeah but it doesn't say that i have the
other thing for it so i can't combine it
all right whatever fine
i've got this giant crystal and a giant
axe or a giant hammer and a giant axe
pretty cool
baby
[Music]
oh hi hello
what you're the real deal ethan
well done quit hiding [ __ ]
i'm not letting you get out of this cool
your jets
just a little bit more and you're all
wrapped up
i'll lend you a hand so in exchange
in exchange what first of all come to me
put all the flasks in the altar and i'm
sure you'll figure the rest out
see you ethan see you
heisenberg
i'll go to the altar and i'll put all
the flasks you could have just
not put my baby in a bunch of bottles
and i wouldn't have to reassemble her
but anyway guess i'll meet you at the
alder
i got googly elmo's plate
hey this looks oh no it's not football
here at all anyway i got googly elmo's
plate that's really good i guess um time
to go
put my baby in a in an altar
am i driving this thing i sure am aren't
i
hmm
i don't like sewers in resident evil
games they're usually end poorly for me
somehow i don't think this one's going
to be any different
it were different it tore
it twere different hmm
well good good stuff good stuff
everybody thank you so much for being
here
um which way to go
oh
i know where you pop out of i know where
you pop out of
neat oh that i could've
well i could have done that but i'm
gonna go back down
all right what else is down here hello
hello someone being spooky down here
who's been spooky
is it one of lady dimmadome's daughters
that i somehow missed
hmm photo of a phantom fish
well you could let me look at it that'd
be cool too
if you did that photo of a phantom fish
well it doesn't exist i guess
photo of a fan of fish here we go
[Music]
okay all right i know what that is okay
cool i think
i think i do i remember there being
something like that
vaguely cadu implantation notes
okay 21 male silversmith scars from
pneumonia low affinity cadu filled grow
body transformation drop in cognition
another likeness into pasture
um 21 female no occupation no history of
illness results
death alcena 44 female noble descent not
from the village hereditary blood
disease very high affinity no loss of
cognition
arbitrarily able to control body
transformation applied cognition control
procedure
sent for observation
noble descendant indeed
[Music]
she was kadude i see babe
you hear that babe babe how's your caddo
babe you didn't tell me you had kadu
hey whoa okay this is a little
there's a little silly
hey
yeah all right now why
why did you [ __ ] feel the need to oh
i
you did it
got him a few too many bullets but
that's okay i've got more to spare
i do i do
i wish i could find that knife again i
bet it's somewhere in the game it fell
it's gotta exist the super knife
you know what me mean i bet it fell
somewhere in the game and you could go
and find it at any moment
but i didn't because i'm kind of a dick
don't even try
excuse me
excuse me
uh biggins okay let's not fight the
biggens right now
let's go take care of ourselves a little
bit we'll save the biggins for later
because i don't exactly have the things
and i have no idea how to
switch over to flashbangs not that that
would be very helpful for me
but let's not do that right now let's
just not deal with that
let's go talk to this dude
what's up this dude hey how you doing
dude
how you doing let me see my greatest
pleasure to see you return alive
thank you appreciate that big preach
[Music]
okay i could do this ooh
[Music]
protein rich for turning boys into
bastions
hell yeah hell yeah i could do that
let's do that all right wait no no no no
no uh carry on i can hardly wait
just excuse me pork
finished thanks baby love for you to
enjoy as well
it was really for me yeah it was it was
actually only for me you you thought you
were just gonna eat it
yourself all right but that's good i
wouldn't mind having that again
well we can't so shut up all right um
i've procured some new items for you mr
winter
have you now have you well that's
wonderful that's so grand
even though i don't need that at all
um oh gosh you know
oh my goodness how could i
i could never uh is there anything i
could sell those axe and the
crystal hammer yeah the crystal axe
this one says it's too big to use but
this one does not say it's too big to
use
you know what i mean whatever i'm gonna
sell them i don't care i wouldn't use
them anyway
not my style
okay the wolf spain
okay how about i buy this thing back
because why not i can see why you'd be
interested in that
can you can you i don't want more range
on the scope i really don't i feel like
that's
unnecessary
okay let's get the sniper rifle recipe
let's go ahead and get the sniper rifle
bullets
let's customize the snipey riffy more
dabblage more
dabblage of course these hands are more
dexterous than one might think
i didn't think that they weren't uh so
she thank you for your patronage
we're gonna shortcut the four we got all
that
we're gonna move these around move this
around move this around i've got so many
bullets let's come by and equip this to
this
bam we're good there bada bing bada
bingo
time to go huntin oh wait i forgot we're
ready for this aren't we
aren't we ready for this
there's no reason not to do this right
now is there
jesus what was that that's not being so
creepy to the baby
still recording okay
i mean they did tear the baby into
pieces so that's not really
i guess i'm not asking for too much
maybe i am can you stop moaning over
there
yeah this is gonna work
actually i have no idea what this is
gonna do but he's gonna do
something
i'm carrying this now
what
[Music]
uh-huh oh yeah
oh that's normal oh that's what we call
normal
okay well before we do that i'm gonna
have to say goodbye for now thank you
everybody so much for watching we've got
a baby to save i think unless
i just just put the pieces of my baby in
there
but anyway thank you be sure to check
out distractible please do actually
there's a link right down there in the
description it's a great show i think
you'll find it
very funny we're gonna evolve the
concept as time goes on
and be sure to follow and subscribe
wherever you do listen to podcast it's
great fun
i think you'll enjoy it a lot link right
down there please click it give it a
chance
i would owe you a big and you can click
and just see which podcast it's
available on
see where you listen to it and if you
don't listen to podcast uh it's just bob
wade and i
being stupid together and having fun so
that's pretty much it so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you